Все мы понимаем что везение - это основа
или основное условие достижения любых
действительно крутых неимоверных
результатов мы все хотим быть везучим
недаром Почти в каждом пожелании мы
желаем друг другу удачи а не усердия
удача способна любого человека сделать
любым независимо от его начальных
условий но удача она Как дочь везения
Такая дама Очень капризная и не каждому
Она улыбается Как
поётся знаменитые песни из фильма Белое
солнце в пустыни Ваше благородие госпожа
удача для кого-то доброе для кого
[музыка]
иначе это третье видео продолжающееся
напомню суперпозиция - это про то как
сделать такую ситуацию при которой тебе
закономерно везёт и весь мир хочешь
чтобы ты добивался своих целей сегодня
мы поговорим о том как оседлать везение
и сделать его закономерным о том что
такое везение почему оно случается и
различные точки зрения на этот феномен
особый упор мы сделаем на том что такое
закономерное везение каким оно бывает и
где оно случается Итак тема сегодняшнего
видео закономерное в везение она будет
полезна всем но особенно она будет
полезна для тех кто амбициозен и
стремится достичь максимальных высот в
бизнесе инвестициях и в жизни поняв
концепцию закономерного везения вы
поймёте что везение Оказывается это не
просто слепой случай какой-то как Многие
думают что оказывается вполне возможно
сделать так чтобы вам везло причём не
иногда а постоянно
подписывайтесь на мой канал нажимайте
колокольчик активно комментируйте и
обязательно Поделитесь этим видео с теми
людьми которых вы считаете
амбициозны А если Вас интересуют такие и
другие инсайты в отношении моей жизни и
бизнеса подписывайтесь на мой Telegram
канал ссылку я оставлю
внизу когда мы говорим о везении мы
сразу же подразумеваем случайность
считаем что везение или удача - это
плодь случая которые невозможно
предсказать а управлять им уж тем более
Хотя в то же время Вы наверняка немало
встречали людей которым везёт по жизни
которым везёт постоянно или очень часто
настолько часто что это даже не
объяснить просто случаем никакая Теория
вероятности в случае с ними не работает
Однажды когда мы с друзьями поехали в
экспедицию на квадроциклах Один мой друг
играя в нарды он выкинул 11 дуб подряд
Ну это почти невозможно шанс этого
настолько малы что можно сказать что это
невозможно В принципе Однако же он
сделал это и я не единственный свидетель
этому и кстати ему всегда везёт в
азартные игры самое интересное что
именно только в этой сфере да и у меня в
жизни и в бизнесе случалось очень много
чудес которые ни одна наука не в
состояние объяснить Так что жизнь полна
чудес Хорошо быть везунчиком но как быть
если ты не такой или как повернуть своё
везение на те сферы Где тебе это нужно
Давайте разбираться для начала Давайте я
вам дам своё определение слову везение
везение - это благоприятное стечение
временных и пространственных
обстоятельств Это то что в народе
Говорят он оказался в нужное время в
нужном месте смотрите бывает случайное
везение а бывает закономерное везение
случайное везение - это благоприятное
стечение временных и пространственных
обстоятельств независимо от действий
человека в то время как закономерное
везение - это следствие целенаправленных
мыслей и действий а также ожиданий
человека по созданию либо нахождению в
благоприятных временных и
пространственных
обстоятельствах как мы видим разница в
двух типах везения определяется только
ролью человека А смотрите В случайном
везении и его роль пассивно От него
ничего не зависит а в закономерно
везении его роль активна везение
является следствием его мыслей действий
и ожиданий приведу вам пример вот
Представьте что человек случайно
оказался на рыбалке взял удочку насадил
на крючок то что попалось под руку и
забросил удочку в первую попавшийся ру
Как вы думаете Какова вероятность того
что он поймает хоть какую-то рыбу Не
говоря уже там о крупном саза Ну
вероятность Конечно есть но она почти
равна нулю так вот если он вдруг поймает
крупного сазана это будет случайное или
Слепое везение Этот человек похож на
человека который решил заработать на
случайных заработках не создавая бизнес
если приводить аналогию из жизни а
теперь представьте себе другую ситуацию
человек поставил себе цель поймать
крупного сазана он купил себе
соответствующие снасти именно на сазана
он изучил что сазан любит и купил
соответствующую наживку он узнал В каком
водоёме этот сазан водится узнал В какое
время они лучше всего клюют он таким
образом приехал на водоём и сел рыбачить
Как вы думаете каковы его шансы Вы ведь
понимаете что его шансы гораздо гораздо
можно сказать даже в разы выше чем у
первого случайного рыбака так вот этот
человек похож на человека который создал
бизнес он изучил Где водится рыба или
его целевые потребители он насадил
правильную наживку сел в подходящее
место Как вы думаете кому больше повезёт
и в бизнесе и на рыбалке конечно же
второму который подготовился лучше Ну а
теперь представьте себе третьего
человека он сделал тоже самое что и
второй но только вместо одной удочки он
забросил 10 удочек сразу же как вы
думаете у него больше шансов Ну конечно
же у него шансов ещё больше он знаете
похож на бизнесмена который развивает не
там например не просто кофейню а целую
сеть кофеин у него шансы на успех
гораздо больше чем у того кто сидит с
одной удочкой Ну и вот пока эти Трое
рыбачат в это время к берегу подъехала
там какая-нибудь Лада Нива оттуда
вывалились три мужика один из них начал
выгружать палатку и устанавливать второй
разжигать мангал а третий надул
резиновую лодку и перекрыл сетью весь
водоём а теперь как вы думаете У кого
больше шансов у первого второго третьего
или у этих трёх мужиков которые
подъехали только
что конечно же у этих трёх мужиков
которые перекрыли озеро сетью это и есть
закономерное везение если у первых трёх
рыбаков вопрос стоит в том вообще
повезёт им или нет то у вот этих трёх
мужиков которые поставили сеть вопрос
стоит только в том когда повезёт и Что
им делать с излишками Вот именно так и
работает закономерное везение в случае с
мужиками которые перекрыли озеро сетью
закономерное везение заключается в том
Какое орудие или инструмент Они
использовали Дело в том что у разных
инструментов разный потенциал
закономерного везения или Помните я
говорил вам в предыдущем видео что очень
важно инструменты иметь инструменты
масштабирования вашей удачи так вот
выбор правильного инструмента
компенсирует нехватку знаний и навыков
благодаря тому что он больше использует
закономерное везение и площадь
закономерное везение - Это не то что с
вами случается или там случится в
будущем или нет Это то что должно с вами
случиться однако для того чтобы
закономерное везение с вами случилось
Просто наличие правильного инструмента
мало Вы должны понимать в каких водоёмах
стоить сеть Как создавать или учитывать
течения или тренды Как находить рыбу или
хорошие возможности что вообще такое
сеть и как её
выстраивать То есть Вам тоже нужны
знания но это уже знания просто другого
рода это другой уровень или другое
понимание процесса в целом именно про
такой случай и сказал Альберт Эйнштейн
решите проблему находясь на том же
уровне на котором вы её создали Так что
в этом случае нужно делать не то что все
делают и не так как все делают нужно
делать что-то другое и нужно делать это
по-другому
закономерное везение - это совокупность
ваших мыслей действий и
ожиданий это управляемый процесс каждый
из вас может сделать себя более или
менее везучим для этого м размышлять
наблюдать за жизнью и различными
проявлениями везения Ну и конечно же
максимально расширять свою сеть А что
значит расширять свою сеть ну если
сказать по-простому это всё время
оказываться в нужное время в нужном
месте а для этого вы должны
максимизировать площадь своего Контакта
с этим миром иначе Как можно оказаться в
нужное время в нужном месте потому что
это нужное время и нужное место всегда
меняется А вам нужно везде успевать и
оказываться там точно также делает
квантовая частица квантовая частица в
любое время может находиться в любой
точке пространства и про такую ситуацию
говорят что квантовая частица находится
в
суперпозиции что бы и где бы не
произошло что-либо в любой точке
пространства квантовая частица Может
быть там и это главный секрет
закономерного везения вам нужно всё
время оказываться там где что-то
происходит где складываются
благоприятные обстоятельства в вашу
пользу для того чтобы вам всё время
оказываться в нужное время и в нужном
месте Вам нужно быть как квантовая
частица в суперпозиции А как это можно
сделать спросите вы ведь у меня ведь
одно тело Я же не могу оказываться везде
и всегда дам вам один самый простой
пример
партнёрство чем оно хорошо когда парт
доверяют друг другу и у них общие
интересы то они совместно покрывают
пространство и больше времени Ну это ВС
равно как если бы вы клонировали себя и
у вас было бы несколько тел например
один может находиться в конференции
где-нибудь где Может познакомиться с
какими-то крутыми людьми и обрести новые
связи а второй в это время может быть
там в бане с друзьями где услышат
хорошую идею а третий в это время может
быть на другом мероприятии или деловой
встречи где узнает Про шикарную там
сделку видите Когда у них общие интересы
они втроём покрывают больше времени и
больше пространства и именно благодаря
этому Они видят и получают больше
возможностей чем один человек
миллиардеры редко появляются в
одиночестве вообще миллиардер сво - это
командный или партнёрский вид спорта
далеко ходить не надо вот в той же
силиконовой долине если взять Мафию
PayPal так называемой откуда ило мас
кстати тоже вышел из одной компании
вышла целая группа миллиардеров но
Возьмите в России там Альфа Group
Интерос Group в каждой из них родилось
сразу несколько миллиардеров поэтому
миллиардер сво или любое достижение
крупного успеха - это командный вид
спорта Как создавать условия при которых
вы сможете оседлать закономерное везение
я Обучаю на своей премиальной программе
акме акме в переводе с древнегреческого
обозначает точку наивысшего расцвета
потенциала человека я убеждён что Только
благодаря полному раскрытию своего
потенциала человек сможет выстроить
супер позицию в результате которой он
сможет достичь максимального
закономерного
везения если вам интересно переходите по
ссылке которую я оставлю внизу Ну а я на
этом прощаюсь в следующих видео мы
рассмотрим инструменты суперпозиции
[музыка]